-It's a holiday coming up.
Do you have plans?
-Mainly, Christmas cookies
-Christmas cookies.
-My wife and I are throwin
a party tomorrow night.
We spend all day today and mos
of tomorrow Christmas cookies.
-Are they the kind of Christma
cookies when if as a guest
to your party, people will see
them and be impressed?
-We're counting on that.
-Okay. Gotcha.
-And I -- at the moment, I'm all
cinnamon, nutmeg, allspice
-Gotcha. That's sort of --
That's the era of your lif
you're living through.
Those are your spices.
-That's right.
-This is not -- this is --
Roger Ailes is not
a Christmassy kind of guy.
-It's not a holiday film.
-Yes.
[ Laughter ]
-It's opening
during the holidays.
-But do not mistake it
for a holiday film.
-But in Hollywood, you know,
Christmas is award season.
So I guess it is.
-There you go.
What is a better gift
than an award?
You're Roger Ailes.
You play Roger Ailes
in this film,
and it takes place in 2015
Some of the things
that were happening then wer
sort of Megyn Kelly questionin
Donald Trump in a debate.
Gretchen Carlson
filing a sexual harassment sui
against the network.
And this is all sort of a
precursor to the Me Too movement
which is obviously very clos
to it but right before it.
Was it interesting
to sort of delve into --
you know, this is
a historical piece,
but it's sort of recent history.
-Very much so.
It was an amazing feeling
to be doing a film like this
that is so much at
the center of everybody's
consciousness these days.
This really was
a kind of origin story.
When the Harvey Weinstein
scandal came along,
that's when the dam broke.
Well, this was
the hole in the dam.
-Yeah.
-And an incredible --
It was a period of
only about three weeks
when so much happened
and Roger Ailes' life
was just washed away.
Karma caught up with him.
-You say that karma
caught up with him,
and I think a lot of peopl
would agree with you.
No matter what you think,
obviously this is a guy
who built an empire,
as referenced in that clip
Many people would have negativ
opinions of Roger Ailes.
When you play someone like that,
do you have to find a way to b
empathetic towards them or can
you play someone hateful
and as an actor
be hateful as well?
-Well, I've thought about that
a lot over the years
because I've played
a lot of villains.
I always say I'm on the side o
whatever character I'm playing
It's just a matter of plumbing
the depths, trying to empathize,
look inside, and what make
that person tick.
It's not necessarily
exonerating Roger Ailes
or building sympathy for him
but it is trying to
kind of explain -- explain him
-Yeah.
-Give a little emotional
authenticity to him.
I mean, it seems to me
that everyone --
A villain like this
lives a life of shame.
You know, he carries
this terrific guilty secre
and if you --
if you're that ashamed,
surely there's levels
of remorse and regret.
That's kind of what I look for
I mean, it's just a kind o
conflict inside the character.
-And for someone who, you know
built a television empire,
there's not a ton of --
Was there a ton of tape
for you to go on?
Was there a lot
for the purposes of research
-It was very hard.
I found what I could,
but Roger himself,
I don't think he liked
to be photographed.
Otherwise, I could have
found a lot more.
I finally found his voice
in a kind of
media symposium interview
he did and was surprised.
It was the first time
I'd heard his voice.
It was a very kind of buoyan
and cheerful Midwestern accent
Very different
from a villain's voice.
-Yeah.
-You know.
-Very good for you.
-Yeah.
You have a good buoyant voice.
-As a matter of fact,
he grew up in Warren, Ohio
I spent two years of
my childhood in Akron,
which is right nearby.
So turns out
we had that in common.
-That's amazing.
You -- There's a lot of --
You had a --
Was it your neighbor
that knew him
or you had a friend
who used to be his neighbor?
-No, not neighbor. Oh, I know.
Yes. Our mutual friends,
Bonnie and Terry Turner.
-Oh, yeah, of course.
-They're in Cold Spring.
Their property abutted Roger's
And Bonnie told me
that one day in a diner,
she saw Roger Ailes
eat an entire meat pizza.
-Wow.
[ Laughter ]
-I never even heard the phrase
"meat pizza."
-Yeah, certainly.
It seems like
a special order maybe. Yeah.